alright this is war so choose a side
between Nazis and a tank full of
that's my choice that's all
I've got
that's fury so fury is a movie
set in World War 2 it follows this crew
of mists I don't even want to call them
mister they're really dicks or a crew of
douchebags in a tank led by Brad Pitt
and then this new guy comes into the
scenes as a young kid he's seen no
action whatsoever so ultimately they're
like oh you're an outcast you feel like
they don't accept him and you kind of
chalk it up to first-day hazing but this
movie lasts about 1 or 2 days I think
two days max probably one day in which
case the hazing never ends so he never
bonds with them so you just feel like
he's an outsider and you root for him
you see them all is the and
among all this you have the standard
world war two situations fights and
heads exploding and artillery going off
now let's talk about what the movie did
right first of all like I said the war
scenes are actually really exciting
they're good when it's intense its
intense you feel like you're in the tank
you feel like you're part of the crew it
makes you root for the new kid and
that's good cuz you're supposed to root
for the new kid and you grasp the
concept that war is ugly it's very
violent there's nothing heroic about it
you feel like finally a movie did
something to show you that there are no
medals no was like oh yeah that was
glorious and thank you heroes and
no it's just all dirty and no one wants
to be there it is just anger but they do
it because they have to but doesn't
change the fact that it is very ugly and
sometimes to fight monsters you have to
be an even Shia LaBeouf was good
in the movie I am a person I like a
comeback Shia LaBeouf is had his fair
share of problems in the past few years
but I want to see the dude succeed and
this movie shows that he is a good actor
so just dude seriously keep yourself out
of the tabloids and I think your on your
pad okay that being said here's me I
hate this guy I'm gonna get that out of
the way right now there are
and then there are bullies then
there's this guy this guy is the worst
kind of because he's a dumb
idiot but he just overpowers everybody
in the room because he's insecure and
that's what bullies do and but I
was watching it I was like I don't like
you the bummer is when he's being a dick
no one does anything to stop him and
they actually kind of like laugh and
cackle also so when this dude is
overpowering the new kid and giving him
and everyone's joining in and
laughing and giving him I put them
all in the same boat and I'm like I'm
now like none of you and I would chalk
this up to me and my delicate
sensibilities but the fact is it's part
of the moving in order for me to care
about the people in the tank other than
the kid you actually do care about you
have to like them and now I don't like
them now I'm not rooting for anybody and
this is a problem because when this
is going down I'm just like can a piece
of shrapnel just blow him the in
half and I'm not supposed to think like
that and it's really not just him Brad
Pitt does something early on when this
kid comes on to their team that he makes
the kid do something that is against his
moral code rap is just smacking him
around like dude would do it she puts
his hand on the I mean alright this
isn't really a big thing he kills a guy
Brandon he was a Nazi but he was a
prisoner I'm just saying the kid didn't
want to do it it's easy to say yeah he
was a Nazi burn em all but I kind of see
it like far American when he was like
why did that guy gear up why was he
fighting us what lies was he told was he
threatened and later on in this movie he
does show a bunch of children like
hanging and they're dead and have signs
around their necks saying we wouldn't
fight so knowing that the SS would do
that to people who wouldn't fight but if
that's what happened to this guy what if
they strung up a bunch of kids and
looked at this guy and they were like
you're gonna fight for us otherwise
we're gonna do that to your children you
can go round and round and round but the
guy isn't unarmed prisoner now and
anyone sensibilities about it don't
matter except the kid in this thing so
when he's like I don't want to kill the
unarmed prisoner and Brad Pitt's
character makes it happen now I'm like
alright Brad Pitt's characters a dick
it's kind of like morality rape you
can't force someone to do something like
that Michael Pena actually added
something to it every time he was kind
of a dick he was kind of funny about it
I like that if you're gonna be a dick
kind of be funny about it it wasn't
until this scene in the movie that I
think should have just been taken
completely out of the movie there's a
scene where they go into this house and
they have dinner with these two girls as
well as impliedly alright the young kid
can have sex with one of them but you're
like is that just is that the spoils of
war point is thirty minutes later I was
like this scene is still happening why
and among Brad Pitt the new kid playing
house with these two German girls then
the entire crew comes in and then Shane
from The Walking Dead starts acting like
a complete dick again it was the scene
that made me go you know what I don't
like anybody if the scene wasn't in it I
wouldn't have gotten bored I wouldn't
have hated everybody in the tank as much
seriously director's cut of the blu-ray
take that scene out it would make the
movie better it'd make the movie
stronger and make you care more about
the characters Indian theories a well
acted movie that does
display its point which is more as ugly
and history's violent and aside from the
fact that I rooted for the kid the
entire time and actually started to root
for Brad Pitt at the end of the movie
the tank is full of a company full of
that you don't really care
about a movie go rides to a halt about
halfway through the actions exciting the
tank stuff is exciting instant effective
war movie though I will end up saying
theory is still a good time no alcohol
required are so theory have you seen it
what did you think about it what's your
favorite war movie of all time whatever
it is comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more